la première image de vous à la
télévision date de 1986 et l'époque de
la mobilisation contre la loi devaquet
en vous découvre sur le plateau de
michel polac 19 ans déjà engagé avec
d'autres étudiants vous restez derrière
vous ne prenez pas encore la parole ni
la lumière mais avec votre maître 92 on
ne peut pas vous raté
qu'il était celui parmi vous parmi des
étudiants qui étaient avec jérôme
lorsqu'il a reçu sa grenade penchez-vous
oui alors comment ça s'est passé
j'aimerais dire à van avant de commencer
tout débat qu'on aimerait
demandé une minute de silence pour tous
les blessés du nord
c'est cette révolte de jeunesse qui vous
a donné le goût de l'engagement
j'étais déjà dans une famille très
politique on allait distribuer des
tracts coller des affiches gamin mais
c'est vrai que je pense que chaque
génération d'une certaine façon à son
à son rituel d'engagement politique et
c'est vrai que là la mobilisation contre
la loi devaquet
les violences policières évidemment la
mort de malik oussékine ça forge sa
forge un caractère politique
[Musique]
c'est une image furtive une archive de
73 un portrait de votre père jean marie
le pen qui vient de créer le front
national vous avez 5 ans
[Musique]
vous êtes la petite dernière avec le
gros nounours dans les bras et le
chandail à rayures et donc pour vous une
première apparition dans un reportage
politique sans que vous l'ayez souhaité
oui c'est vrai on a on a été très vite
mis devant les caméras mais sté l'époque
c'était c'était la grande époque
enfin le début de l'époque reagan de
l'époque
où en réalité ont montré la vie de
famille en fête est donc tout au long de
la vie politique de mon père on a
souvent fait l'objet de reportages mais
ça c'est effectivement la première image
avec le chien rainbow que vous ne voyez
pas mais que vous entendez et dans cet
appartement qui était un appartement
assez modeste du 15e arrondissement dans
lequel nous vivions
qui plus tard sera le logement qui est
qui qui explosera qui sera dévastée
[Musique]
on vous retrouve même si vous n'êtes pas
à l'image dans un coup de force contre
une célèbre épicerie de luxe à paris
aux jets d eau vous y étiez oui aux cris
de les fauchés chez fauchon
plus d'une centaine de jeunes chômeurs
et des membres des jeunesses communistes
ont occupé samedi en début d'après-midi
la célèbre épicerie de luxe fauchon
place de la madeleine
après s'être servis dans le magasin les
jeunes ont présenté une vendeuse des
bons d'achats d'actifs j'étais dans
l'image
occuper ce magasin
trouver des bouteilles de digestif
1200000 la grèce il y a dans ce pays les
gens qui n'ont rien absolument rien pour
vivre pour passer les fêtes et d'autres
qui ont toujours au poids grandissant
des deux
un luxe insolent les manifestants ont
été délogés par la police violemment
selon louis violemment on a pris des
coups de matraque des magasins tout
rentrait dans l'ordre il m'a semblé
reconnaître jacques perreux le leader
des jeunes communistes de l'époque et et
vous même un jeune âge je crois pas je
suis avec mes copains on était ensemble
et je les ai reconnus donc je devais
être derrière avec eux mais je m'en
souviens parfaitement ont dénoncé
effectivement cette société à deux
vitesses je me demande si c'est pas moi
qui tourne le dos je vois qu'il ya
olivier marché avec qui je suis là qui
est la première
et on est toujours ensemble d'ailleurs
et donc on à en dénoncer donc
ses magasins pour les riches et en même
temps une société du chômage qui était
en train de grandir et c'était
insupportable ont dénoncé des emprunts
giscard qui avaient été mises en place
ou en gros en plus quand on était riche
on pouvait emprunter avec des intérêts
derrière qui nous faisait gagner de
l'argent on a été
évacuée manu militari par les crs on a
pris des coups sur la tête et à la
sortie de ce magasin j'ai été embarqué
je me suis retrouvé dans un commissariat
où j'ai été mis nu pour
certainement pour m'humilier ils m'ont
fait mettre à poil voilà ils m'ont
laissé à poil comme ça pendant un long
moment
pour puis après ils m'ont demandé de me
rhabiller et puis dans la nuit j'ai été
j'ai été libéré
je vois là je m'en souviens ça m'a
marqué
[Musique]
avant d'être un homme politique vous
êtes d'abord un paysage celui de votre
valley la vallée d'aspe les dans tous
les pores de votre poids de vous
constituez vous détermine c'est une
vallée des pyrénées en béarn votre
village s'appelle lourdios ichère 136
âmes aujourd'hui et tous les ans un
rituel la fête de la transhumance la
montée des troupeaux dans les hauteurs
c'est un reportage de 99 ans vous voir
avec votre béret faisait déjà le maire
de ce village
la transhumance une activité importante
en béarn 150 berger gagne les estives il
représente environ 450 éleveurs pour un
cheptel de près de 70000 brody et un
millier de vaches rassemblés à l'entrée
du village les touristes mais aussi les
habitants de la vallée sont venus
partager l'événement les troupeaux sont
marqués avant de gagner la montagne 90%
des actifs de lourdios cent des vergers
aux des pasteurs étrangement en tout cas
et nous avons encore trente
exploitations agricoles qui sont occupés
ce qui n'est pas pour ça ordinaire et
puis comme vous le voyez
l'ensemble des prairies deschamps sont
entretenus je dirais presque jardiner
ça a bougé depuis
est ce que ça changera vous me parlez
j'étais en train de me retrouver et
oui parce que malheureusement nous avons
perdu
beaucoup de bras l'exode a fini par nous
atteindre aussi avec ma plus de retard
qu'ailleurs il y a un petit peu plus de
de rance et d'arbres qui ont poussé mais
malgré tout
c'est pas mal par rapport au reste du
territoire français qui nous ressemble
[Musique]
la première fois que vous apparaissez à
la télévision c'est pour protester avec
d'autres élèves de l'ena vous occuper
l'école pour refuser son transfert de
paris à strasbourg nous sommes en 91
vous avez 24 ans
ils s'y sentent tellement bien dans leur
école parisienne de la rue de
l'université qu'ils n'ont plus envie de
la quitter mais mme lanusse pense pas
qu'un jour j'aurai l'honneur de me
coucher sur la moquette l'amphithéâtre
jean moulin mais il s'agissait de
montrer malgré son que loin d'être
coupée la réalité sociale de ce pays
nous pouvions garder près des
préoccupations theater le grand public
ne connaît mal sinon il serait qu'on
n'est pas les polars en cravate et henri
stoll
ne reconnaît pas quentin de passe dans
la rue nous sommes des hommes et des
femmes comme tout le monde comme disait
ma camarade des énarques qui ont un père
une mère j'espère que tout le monde en
est conscient et tout ce que vous direz
sourds oui oui je voudrais dormir
combat perdu avec le recul vous diriez
mauvais combat
notre combat c'était pour dire que les
énarques et devaient être formés non pas
en province mais au plus près les
administrations centrales ce
déménagement à strasbourg il était très
symbolique c'était l'idée de
dalé m en province les mets aux
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui l'ena va être
une école de formation de toutes les
administrations
et aujourd'hui ce campus à strasbourg il
a trouvé son équilibre mais à l'époque
ça nous paraissait assez démagogique
comme proposition ça veut dire qu'il
faut pas toujours écouter les jeunes ou
qui n'ont pas toujours raison ouais ça
veut dire que
en fait c'était vraiment surtout du
symbolique et que ça nous paraissait
effectivement
uniquement symbolique et pas très très
efficace sur le dans la pratique
d'ailleurs pendant des années les
énarques ont eu des problèmes à faire
venir leurs professeurs jusqu'à
strasbourg parce que les professeurs ne
voulait pas venir il est maintenant
l'école a trouvé son son équilibre et
c'est tant mieux pour elle
[Musique]
la première fois que vous apparaissez à
la télévision c'est un gréviste déjà
enseignante grévistes mobilisés contre
la réforme fillon en 2003 et pour votre
future retraite
je vais partir à la retraite au delà de
2020 donc il faudra cotiser jusqu'à 68
ans puisque j'ai commencé à travailler à
26 ans et je partirai électrique et
passion de mon salaire net vous militez
depuis l'adolescence 17 18 ans depuis 18
ans depuis 18 ans surtout et et pourquoi
avoir choisi lutte ouvrière c'est vrai
que moi dès l'âge de 16 ans 17 ans
j'étais quand même révolté parce que je
voyais j'étais révoltée par par les
injustices part par la faim dans le
monde aussi il y avait eu en 86 une
famine en éthiopie enfin voila je ne me
voyais pas ne rien faire voilà tout
simplement jeu pour moi c'était ce
n'était pas possible d'accepter ça je
voyais bien je vous ai bien que ici en
france les poubelles recharger et sait
comment les ccc ces enfants ces femmes
mourir de faim je ne comprenais pas et
donc ma première impulsion s'était
finalement de d'aller vers les
associations humanitaires et puis au
lycée à lyon je suis parti faire un
sport études à à lyon j'ai rencontré des
jeunes des jeunes qui avaient des idées
qui avait des idées communistes qui
m'ont fait découvrir
donc le manifeste du parti communiste
qui ont fait découvrir les idées
révolutionnaires et qui m'ont fait
découvrir aussi la force du mouvement
ouvrier ça c'est quelque chose que
vraiment j'ai découvert parce que
j'étais moi même issu d'un milieu plutôt
commerçants agricole puis tu vois la
rural et
j'ai découvert donc cette force là qui
avait déjà tellement fait pour faire
avancer la société et donc je me suis
cela m'a convaincu cela m'a convaincu à
l'époque il y avait le parti communiste
mais qui venait de gouverner qui venait
de gouverner qui était pour moi un parti
de gouvernement qui avait finalement qui
était dans le système donc non moi je
cherchais un parti attaché a vraiment
changé la société de fond en comble ça
devait être un parti révolutionnaire et
cela a été les ouvrières
[Musique]
la toute première image de vous date de
1981 et c'est un soir de victoire
électorale vous n'êtes pas encore dans
la lumière mais dans l'ombre d'un
candidat dont vous êtes le directeur de
cabinet claude germond le maire
socialiste de massy qui vient de sortir
le communiste pierre juquin dans la
troisième circonscription de l'essonne
vous avez 30 ans
clermont bien proclamer les voix
obtenues dans cette ville
trente ans
pas encore de demande d'amm et déjà de
l'ambition politique
ouais je l'ambition si vous voulez oui
enfin j'étais un militant très très
engagé pour qui le militantisme
politique est une raison de vivre
et se trouve que je me dis tu es avec un
homme qui était extrêmement motivant il
était secrétaire confédérale de la cgt
et secrétaire national aux entreprises
pour le ps et donc sa manière d'être son
rapport au mouvement ouvrier
était pour moi un repère il était il a
été à repérer immense dans ma vie c'est
tout à fait évident et puis nous
partagions une certitude qui va
peut-être vous surprendre on pensait
réellement qu'on allait faire le
socialisme donc si vous voulez les
questions du type carrière post s'était
pas vraiment le sujet
[Musique]
la première fois que vous apparaissez à
la télévision vous êtes sous préfet
d'ile-de-france et vous devez gérer une
situation de crise le relogement de
familles africaines sans abri qui
campent sur un terrain vague le futur
site de la bibliothèque nationale de
france nous sommes en 91 vrai 30 ans
les premiers expulsés avaient planté
leurs tentes le 13 sur un terrain vague
de la ville de paris s'était vite devenu
un village africain maliens sénégalais
et un bras de fer à trois avec la ville
de paris et les pouvoirs publics mais
l'hiver approche peu de chauffage de
nombreux enfants manque d'hygiène malgré
l'aide des associations et il y a deux
semaines dans l'attentes 85 des rats ont
même mordu deux enfants alors sans
vouloir céder l'état a voulu chercher à
sortir de l'impasse et expérimentés
ainsi un système de logement passerelle
il n'y a pas de prime au logement pour
une occupation illicite simplement il ya
un devoir d'assistance pour des familles
qui sont dans une situation aujourd'hui
très douloureuse à l'avenir quand il y
aura une expulsion les personnes qui ne
trouvera pas où trouveront pas de
logement pourront aller dans des
logements de d'insertion provisoire
gérés par des associations caritatives
grâce à un nouveau financement de la
part de l'état le relogement de familles
immigrées c'était par conviction ou par
devoir
pour le 2e enfant le parent de voir
j'étais serviteur de l'état je me
souviens très bien c'était la première
intervention j'étais avec un grand
préfet deux grands préfet et christian
philip et puis
sauter christian dans cette et olivier
philippe et christian sautter et et il
était tiraillée entre la volonté de pas
faire passer des familles devant
d'autres et puis en même temps de
répondre à une situation humanitaire y
mafieux envoyé au feu parce que je crois
que personne personne voulait intervenir
lors il avait trouvé le petit jeune de
services donc à la fois par deux voire
par conviction et par les serviteurs de
l'état
[Musique]
vous exercez un métier de l'ombre
conseillère technique dans un cabinet
ministériel sous le gouvernement de
lionel jospin vous travaillez pour la
secrétaire d'état aux droits des femmes
et à la formation professionnelle nicole
péry nous sommes en 1998 vous avez 39
ans je crois qu'on est tous conscients
ici que les liens entre emploi et
formation entre travail et formation
sont telles que le sujet ne peut pas
être complètement autonome même si et je
crois que c'est ça qui est important
aussi dans le travail de nicole il faut
qu'on arrive à redéfinir quand même les
finalités propre de la formation vous
souvenez de ce moment de cette première
caméra je me souviens de pas vraiment en
fait de ce moment je me souviens bien
sûr j'étais au cabinet de nicole péry et
de martine aubry puisque c'était le même
ministère et nicole péry et nommé
à la formation professionnelle
on n'est pas très nombreux autour d'elle
à ce moment-là et et je me souviens
qu'on est en train d'essayer de définir
est ce qu'il faut faire une réforme une
grande réforme accompagner on était
aussi dans dans la loi sur les 35 heures
est un peu plus tard nicole péry va
devenir aussi secrétaire d'état aux
droits des femmes mais voilà je me
souviens tout de moi c'était pas quand
même
[Musique]
tous les hommes politiques ont à peu
près les mêmes idées et que tous pensent
exactement à peu près ce qu'il faut
faire mais la différence là nous devons
nous adapter et eux mêmes doivent
s'adapter c'est que la différence va se
faire sur la façon de le faire c'est à
dire sur le style c'est soit la création
de fait permet d'apporter g et la
défense et les rebelles inventa une
passion qui existe non parce qu'il ya
manière et manière d'apporter ses
remèdes il ya la manière lente douce
qui qui est plutôt prudente et il ya la
manière en forme de rupture avec l'un
des otages mais si ça change beaucoup
comme on le fait mais si ça dépend
comment le fait que la mairie est
notamment parti socialiste
mais quand par exemple on dit réduction
des charges sociales il ya manière et
manière de le faire voilà comment ce
fait ont fait brusquement est-ce que
c'est enrichissant sur dix ans c'est pas
la mauvaise c'est intéressant parce que
vous ramenez les politiques à une
question de style à une différence de
forme vous ne diriez plus a aujourd'hui
deux choses d'abord
quel point j'étais mal habillée c'est
j'ai un peu honte rétrospectivement
première chose deuxième chose
[Musique]
nous sommes en 95 vous l'avez dit hein
donc nous sommes trois ans après
maastricht après le référendum sur
maastricht après
si vous voulez je pense que ce que je
dis à l'époque et est tout à fait
conforme à la réalité c'est qu'à partir
de maastricht il n'y a plus de vraie
différence entre la droite et la gauche
vous savez vous connaissez le mot
célèbre de philippe séguin la droite et
la gauche sont des
dés
comment dire des comment il disait des
tickets ou des nand et des détaillants
qui se fournissent au même grossiste
l'europe donc ce que j'ai voulu dire là
c'est ça c'est à dire que
l'europe la construction européenne
maastricht
les pertes de souveraineté que cela a
occasionné la mondialisation tout cela
rares
fait ressembler les politiques fait à
sera de rapprocher des cons les
politiques et que tout est question de
forme donc effectivement pourquoi je ne
le dirais plus aujourd'hui je ne le
dirais plus aujourd'hui non pas parce
que c'est faux puisque sur les
politiques économiques franchement ça
n'a jamais été aussi vrai et d'ailleurs
tous les français ont fini par se rendre
compte de cela je me rappelle que déjà
dans la campagne de 2002 jean pierre
chevènement disait jose rack pour dire
jospin et chirac c'était la même chose
donc c'est une réalité qui a petit à
petit petit à petit s'est imposé on sait
bien que françois hollande a été très
critiqué à gauche parce qu'il faisait
finalement la même politique que la
droite et la droite a été très critiquée
aussi par ce que il faisait la même
politique que la gauche donc je dirais
toujours cela mais en revanche la
nouveauté et c'est sans doute le
justement le sens de ma candidature
c'est que je pense que nous sommes
sortis de la discussion économique et
que nous sommes rentrés dans la
discussion identitaire c'est à dire que
ce n'est plus la question n'est plus
comme depuis l'après guerre jusqu'aux
années 90 comment on répartit la
richesse comme on répartit la croissance
plus ou moins comment l'état intervient
plus ou moins dans l'économie bref on
est sorti d'une discussion économique et
social
comprenez-moi bien ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya plus de questions économiques
il n'y a plus de questions sociales il
savait tout ça existe encore mais comme
comme coeur selon moi de la vie du pays
c'est la question identitaire qui se
pose la question de la survie de la
france de la question du grand
remplacement toutes ces questions que
j'ai posées dans cette présidentielle et
qui pour moi vont déterminent le destin
de la france dans les décennies à venir
[Musique]